يعني
جريمته التي كان يتوحد بها العراق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طائرات امريكيه تقصف مكتبه قناه الجزيره
اسفل القصف الامريكيه البريطانيه لمكتب
الجزيره في العاصمه العراقيه بغداد عن
استشهاد الزميل طارق ايوب
الاولى تلقاها مكتب الجزيره الذي يقع على
نهر دجله وسط العاصمه العراقيه بغداد
البحث عن مكان امن اصبح امرا صعبا
فرق بين احد هو هذا هذي مبنى وزاره
الاعلام وهاي الشوارع كلها يعني امنه
وكلهم ابطال
الدبابات الامريكيه صباح اليوم وتتقدم نحو
مبنى وزاره الاعلام العراقيه
وسط العاصمه بغداد
هكذا بدا الرئيس العراقي السابق صدام حسين
من جلسات المحكمه الجنائيه الحكم على
المدان صدام حسين المجيد
بالاعدام شنقا حتى الموت لارتك
ضد اهلك جيش الجيش العراقي احنا تركنا
اسلحتنا برضاتنا زين قلنا نخلص من الطاقه
اجتنا ناس اكثر من هذا طاغيه هي امريكا